a sister sent me a nude pic like
disgusting yet Salam alaikum what I met
when I gotta care two brothers and
sisters and dear friends and welcome
back to my channel today as you guys
know with my previous one that I did
with the sister about non Muslim asking
for my number the one that we discussed
with it were just discussing with our
sisters and just out of the sisters
perspective inshallah I thought two
sisters yeah I would ask them a question
but there's something really important
yeah I'm gonna tell you guys a message
that I received from a sister and she
was basically saying and she said is it
permissible to pierce my cheeks yeah and
I was thinking to myself why is she
asking them why do you want Peter cheeks
here and kind of by piercing his cheeks
and then what asked her why she was like
oh because if you should ask him for a
friend or herself I don't know just
because I want to have dimples yeah
now as females yourself as sisters self
why does sisters females in general why
do they go to such levels of like I need
to look this way and I need to be like
this and to the level yet you can
appease your cheeks so it looks like you
have dimples
for what so this was something I was
really curious about it and I know that
is insecurity thing but where do you
think that stems from where does that
come from of I have to look this way and
I need to and it's a pattern as changing
now this is a question I want to ask you
guys wedding is coming from
yeah okay so I really feel like maybe
she might be influenced by what's around
her what she's surrounding herself with
what she's looking at what she perceives
as ideal beauty mmm which might not be
correct okay where does this pressure
well where do you think if I said to you
give me three reasons why they feel bad
why do sisters feel like they're ugly
and they have to look a certain way we
need to dress a certain way what are the
three factors or two factors that he
will say influencer Instagram Explorer
page
or she doesn't have right guidance yeah
okay kind of lets you know that I mean
why the reason why we can't do is
because we're changing creation he's
perfect and you know he creates all
things in perfection yes you should have
that idea I'm fine just the way I am
okay no the reason why I did this is
Robin since you're watching especially
sisters as well as because you see I
find him like I really sometimes feel
sad for sisters stating a feminist I'm
like I don't feel that you know you need
help another way I'm just trying to do
an advice here yeah it's because if you
think about here I know I look at the
industry and like for example be a
makeup clothing whatever it's sad
because you want me to feel uglier and
uglier and uglier and then there's this
image that you need to have and there's
people that are actually in implants
yeah in parts of the body just to fit a
certain one lightly to me when you think
about slavery how much money think about
slavery people think about you know
you're in shackles you're in Chains well
I don't be that sleepy anymore
we have become slaves society we're
sisters a common to extreme nipples that
for example be it your eyebrows your
forehead your nose your ears your lips I
swear to God I saw one thing was going
on where they're putting their lips into
this muscle yeah just to make them look
big yeah and what like if that is most
slavery I don't know syphilis if that is
not being slave to your desires and a
society what my eternal injuries and the
reason I'm making this video sisters
Percy you guys specifically is to say
that look you guys are beautiful in the
owner was created you in your own way be
happy because if you're doing it for
society while lying on the dangers are
slightly the society is not gonna be
there for you if you're doing it for a
man
and I'm genuinely believed sisters there
many play a big role and the reason I
say this and I'm gonna bring men and I
do get attached for this but I have to
be real I'm not doing this just to get
brownies from sisters yet because men
have become not every man but become so
low that they are now forcing because
it's not a supply demand and I see it's
like I supplied the monthly yeah it's
like a man has a okay I want you know so
for example a man for example has
certain expectations yes so he's looking
okay I want her to look like this and I
want her to be like that so when this
happens now sisters are thinking you
know if I don't look like this and
behave like this or talk and walk like
this
nobody's gonna want to marry me and this
is same thing that you have with sisters
don't want to wear the hijab or whatever
it may be because it's come to a point
and this is I'll even tell you it's what
what is that I was just so much time
shall come in the earth and the only
reason I'm sharing this is so you guys
can benefit a sister sends me a nude pic
but disgusting yet now and it was
another nude nude yet but the reason I'm
sharing this is you know why because I
said to that sister I will try to
sentence as I said like I said what did
you get out of the okay alright you've
sent it okay
I deleted it but what did you get out of
it but what was it like okay what did
you achieve like is this what your work
is this do you think you're so [ __ ]
what can I put on the table you don't
trust your character your behavior you a
slap your iman oh you had to offer to
another man with your body and it really
saddens me because it's like you're a
human being you're a person you're not
an object you're not a sexual object for
a man that it's sad that you've come to
a level where you're thinking okay how
can I attract that guy okay not with my
intellect with my character the way I
carry myself with my in mind nothing you
stoop to a level where you say Noah I
just have my body to offer and that's
really sad and I want your sisters to
know like I said before don't drop
yourself to these level while
worth more than that we must be Muslim
or non-muslim do not shape your life
around men believe me you can look like
I don't know whose I don't know if they
can Kardashian whatever you guys have in
your head yeah I swear by Allah your
husband if you think okay if I look like
this and behave like this my husband
would not look at another man or gonna
cheat on me I swear by Allah you can
look however you like yeah okay put try
and wasn't afraid if you like I don't
know however is here where the fashion
hates you please your Lord because the
moment you start to please another man
it's like to worship in him it's because
you become a slave to him now now you're
thinking I'm gonna do everything I can
yeah and now you're thinking matters are
in your hand the matters are in the
hands of Allah please Allah make Allah
first in your life then you will not
care about how a man thinks of you how
you look now nobody's saying don't take
care of yourself you can take care of
yourself we also take care also but it's
just had a simple message from me to you
guys will decisions I don't if you guys
want I don't anything mother
I just want to say sometimes I feel like
why women do this I'm not saying sisters
just women in general yeah it's hard
work to strengthen your intellect and to
work on your you know your mind you know
to challenge yourself mentally yeah so
because there's so much media influence
with people like you know the connection
it's excess revenue they find it easier
and it's really to to try and attract
people with their sexuality like I said
before like sisters know your worth know
your value and you know worship and be
enslaved to the one we was created you
because that's true freedom
once you become a slave to a loss panel
tada all you're doing is you're breaking
all these shackles be it men being
fashion being society you're breaking
them and saying you know I'm here to
please my lord
I'm not going to please you you know and
that's where you will get true freedom
because now you don't care about no one
all you care about is my lord how does a
my you know with my characters and my
behavior beautiful to my goal and then
when you do that while lucky you will
taste the beauty of true freedom and you
will not feel like okay oh my gosh do I
look like this or can I go out like this
all that you'll be free from and I hope
inshallah the speaking is benefited you
guys and I thank you sisters for taking
part in Charlotte now I bless you guys
if there's any other topics that you
would like me to discuss with this is
start with the sisters do let me know
inshaallah on the comment section below
and we can have a perspective offices
well that's what main reason I'm doing
this because a lot of times I don't want
to be that we men talk about female
issues yeah and sadly we don't really
have a good role model in the YouTube
scene where we can refer sisters too so
therefore with for this platform even
though there is the emotional terrorism
some sisters out there and earlier
comment
so yeah so I would say comment section
below inshallah and we will bring do
more videos so normally what happen to
worry about okay thank you me one thanks
Arnie subscribe